[Music]
each year students from around the
Institute take part in a design contest
sponsored by the civil engineering
department in which they're all given a
standard kit of parts and asked to build
a structure such as a bridge and build
it and we'll test it ultimately to
failure the goals are to see who can
build the strongest bridge
get the best idea of material behavior
and overall structural configuration
in practice the design of a real bridge
involves a number of things it involves
a good understanding of the fundamental
principles of structural behavior and
how materials work and it also involves
a need to understand how Theory can be
translated into practice how we can
build a real structure from the
educational point of view what we would
like to do is to first have available
for the student a tutor a tutor who
could help the student in understanding
the basic concepts how for example on
the bridge you'd figure out how big the
reactions would be how long the spans of
the bridge ought to be in a general
sentence but we also need to go a step
further when we've run out of theory and
we need to know how can we translate
theory into practice that's the role
that can be played by an advisor an
advisor who's able to say this line on
your drawing or this string on the model
is something that's translated into a
real steel cable that has to be
connected at the pier and at the bridge
and has to say that these crossings of
members really involve making a
connection between things that are 10 or
15 feet deep how that can be built in
practice is an important part of our
educational program
in the laboratory I mentioned that we
would like to have available our
students tutors and advisors tutors to
cover basic fundamental methods and
advisers to deal with practical problems
under project Athena we've been able to
do exactly by building computer software
that can work as a tutor and as an
advisor we've built specifically three
programs one called macavity which deals
with statics of simple beams the second
program called expert which acts as a
source of knowledge about practical
engineering problems and the third growl
Tiger which helps students build models
and structures analyze them and design
their compliments the first program
which I'm going to demonstrate in the
cavity is an expert tutor which deals
with the computing of reactions on a
beam for example the beam that might
have form the middle span of this
particular structure
I've asked macavity the beam tutor to
generate a problem it's produced an
example of a simple beam with two
reactions that are unknown these might
be the piers on the bridge for example a
uniform load across the top which
represents the weight of the bridge and
a concentrated load which would for
example be the weight of a truck going
across what I'm going to do and I have
actually done is to write in some
equations that would help me compute the
values of these reactions and I will
show you the form that they've come into
the program and demonstrate how the
tutor will pick up the mistakes that
I've made the equations which I've
previously input are 2/1 which tries to
sum the forces and 1 which tries to sum
the moments if I solve them I find out
that I'd made some mistakes and so what
I want to do is go to the tutor and find
out what's going on it's building up a
model about me as a student and I'm
going to tell it a particular equation
I'm having problems with and ask it to
help me out it's pulled it out of the
database and right now what's going on
is it's setting up a system of rules
trying to figure out what it is that I'm
trying to do and where I would be
incorrect or correct the specific
mistake I've made here is that the
coefficient of this force f1 shouldn't
be 6
it's attempting to make a diagnosis
first of all what I'm doing it's when
I've made an error can't always be sure
exactly what kind of mistake I've made
so it's going to come back and ask me
for some additional information it's
unable to figure out where I'm trying to
some moments although it did know that's
what I was doing and asked me to tell at
the point which is ten feet from the
left end of the beam it's now made the
diagnosis that I'm incorrect and if I
want to ask some questions I'll just say
why is my equation incorrect and it
gives me a little bit of help that says
my equations incorrect because I've made
errors in specifying some of the moment
arm terms we don't want it immediately
to tell the student exactly what's going
on but to have him try and figure it out
for himself
if I need more help I can ask why again
and it gets more specific it says that F
1 which was the force representing the
truck at the incorrect moment arm and if
I ask it again it tells me exactly what
it should be having reached the end of
the sort of inferencing tree I can tell
it to just fix it and it comes back and
tells me what my equation ought to be
what's important about this particular
program is that it can give personalized
instruction to the student and
non-judgmental health it also doesn't
deal only with two or three candles but
it's able to tackle all of the problems
involving simple beams the student can
continue to change things and really try
out all the different capabilities of
the program until he gets a firm
understanding of the basic principles
the second program that I want to show
you expert is the one which give some
practical advice about a construction
methodology specifically suppose we
wanted to get some information about the
kind of bridge we ought to use program
expert you'll ask some basic questions
from the student about span lengths and
construction capabilities and we'll come
back with a recommendation of a type of
bridge that he ought to use
expert is a simple inference engine
program that can give practical advice
to the students it has access to a
number of databases about particular
tasks what we want to do for this
example is to bring in a database called
bridge which knows some things about
bridge construction and next we want to
run the database answer some questions
and get an appropriate preliminary
design the first thing it needs to know
about our span lengths and let's suppose
in our case that it's not less than 160
feet but it is less than 200 feet in
this case falsework relates to
construction I'm not necessarily sure
whether it's practical or not so I'll
answer maybe it then comes up we want a
viaduct type of bridge and I'll say no
and particularly fast we want to get our
project done quickly so we answer yes
and it comes forward with a diagnosis
the best type of bridge construction
would be a precast balanced a cantilever
segmental method with a constant depth
section now because I'd answered may be
in other words I didn't know if
falsework were practical it's going to
come down and ask me another series of
questions
again it's not a viaduct a bridge in our
case it's a symmetrical three span
bridge
and our span length is less than 650
feet and let's say we want a straight
deck like our model and we don't have
any area behind the abutment for a
special foundation considerations and it
comes up with another diagnosis the
incremental placing method is the way we
ought to build our bridge this approach
the expert advisor although it's based
on a relatively simple method is a very
good way for us to get practical
information to our students
another important educational aspect
this program for example the knowledge
was gathered by by a student that meant
that he had to search through text books
and journal articles and find out the
important questions and the important
methods that might apply in future work
we're going to include also consulting
with outside experts to bring them to
bear on real engineering problems and
specific kinds of details the third
program that I want to show you growl
Tiger is the structural analysis and
model building and design program in
this case the students having decided on
a general structural configuration
perhaps the thing from which they
eventually built the model what they'd
like to do is to be able to run through
an analysis and find out how big the
forces are going to be in the strings or
how much the beam is going to move growl
Tiger allows them to build very rapidly
a mathematical model which gives
reasonably good predictions with
behavior of the actual structure
in growl tiger I can build models of the
structure I've decided to build a model
of my cable bridge and in a few minutes
actually created this numerical model
which shows what it looks like what its
configuration would be and I can size
some of these numbers I put a load on
representing the weight of the bridge
and I can easily run an analysis and
then come back and plot what the
deformed shape of the structure might be
what it's doing is plotting the original
geometry of the bridge then we'll come
back and suggest a scale factor for me
to blow up the displacements and plot it
over the original structure and so we
can see by looking at these things how
the bridge is going to really behave its
actual large bending in the center is
representative of the large moments and
the failure that actually occurred in
our wooden model that the students made
the ultimate goal of our project is to
combine these three approaches the tutor
and the advisor and put them within the
context of a program that can do the
structural analysis and design it's
important that our students have the
ability to run experiments to help
themselves generate those rules about
behavior to figure out the appropriate
kinds of structural configurations that
would be important it represents to my
mind a new way to go about education
where the program the computer can be
used as a source of information as a way
to teach the student and as a way to
demonstrate and as a way to allow him to
experiment